dans les actualités l'ukraine frappée
par une cyber attaque d'ampleur qui a
émis des messages sur les principaux
sites gouvernementaux ukrainien
avertissant les citoyens d'avoir peur et
de s'attendre au pire la russie a bien
sûr déployés cent mille soldats à la
frontière ukrainienne l'union européenne
a condamné ce sabotage informatique et
l'otan va renforcer sa coopération avec
l'ukraine correspondance gulliver craag
le message des hackers qui est apparu
sur le site du ministère des affaires
étrangères ukrainien ce matin ainsi que
le ministère de l'éducation et environ
70 autres sites gouvernementaux à la
capitale et en région selon les
autorités ukrainiennes était écrit en
ukrainien en russe et en polonais
clairement il ya vu une tentative de
faire passer cela pour un message des
nationalistes polonais qui menacerait
les ukrainiens d'une revanche pour les
attaques contre les polonais habitants
en ukraine qui ont eu lieu dans les
années 40 mais un responsable du
ministère des affaires étrangères
ukrainien qu'on avait ce qu'on a pu
joindre ce matin nous a confié que le
cren soupçonne tout de même peut-être
plus tôt la russie dans cette affaire ne
serait ce que parce que la russie a déjà
eu recours à ce genre de tactique les
cyberattaques et les tentatives de créer
des tensions entre polonais et
ukrainiens mais officiellement kiev
n'accuse personne pour le moment mais se
limite à dire que l enquête sur cet
événement et que les données
personnelles des internautes n'ont pas
fuité selon les services de sécurité
ukrainiens il n'y a pas de données
importants qu'ils aient fuité suite à
cette attaque mais bien sûr c'est un
cyber attaque qui intervient dans un
contexte de tension entre l'ukraine et
la russie pendant laquelle le crâne
craint entre autres justement des
cyberattaques venant de la russie et une
théorie pour possible sur ce qui s'est
passé aujourd'hui c'est que c'est une
sorte d'avertissement ou bien juste un
test une tentative de vérifier ce de
quoi les acteurs sont capables